euh il y a un club aussi qui marche
plutôt bien cette année donc c'est dans
le triathlon c'est à Saint-Quentin avec
donc jean-françis rmil est-ce que vous
faites du CRAV Maga du tout est-ce que
ça vous intéresse est-ce vous avez
intérêt à répondre oui peut-être les ont
peut-être pas le physique pour pour
faire du CRAV Maga non on n pas du tout
ce genre de non on on a déjà beaucoup de
travail à faire donc il y a beaucoup
d'entraînement donc on n pas vraiment le
temps de faire autre chose hein vous
vous en sortez bien mais vous courrez
très vite donc peut-être que ça ça
équilibre ça peut équilibrer ouais ça
peut et donc du coup au sein de cette de
cette équipe qui qui a connu sa première
division en élite cette année il y a un
jeune qui monte en puissance c'est
Thomas André qui a connu son premier
titre mondial espoir en duathlon donc le
duathlon pour bien comprendre ces deux
épreuves la course à pied et le vélo
nous l'avons suivi justement il y a
quelques jours à l'entraînement après ce
beau titre
mondial à le tri c'est ça occupe 100 %
de 100 % de ma vie je respire je vis
pour le triathlon quoi tout est fait
tout ma vie est orientée vers le
triathlon pour le triathlon Thomas André
n'est pas le génie de son sport et il le
sait mais ce Borau de travail vient de
remporter les championnats du monde
espoir de duathlon à 22 ans se licencié
du triathlon club de 50 ans en Eveline
arrive à maturité pourtant son
apprentissage du haut niveau a été
difficile intégré au pôle espoir
français en 2005 le natif de Marseille
est écarté de la structure pour manque
de résultat je faisais une saison
correcte en première année espoir
j'avais j'avis fait 5e au championnat de
France espoir pour une première année
c'est c'était honnête en plus sur une
course difficile j'avais réussi à faire
16e sur une coupe d'Europe élite j'avais
fait des résultats corrects mais la féd
attendait de moi des des résultats
excellents parce que ça faisait 5 ans
que j'étais sur une structure donc il
voulait il voulait déjà un champion quoi
j'étais pas j'étais pas un champion ce
champion Thomas André a appris à le
devenir malade juste avant les
championnats du monde à Nancy il bat
pourtant ce jour-là son record sur la
course à pied son point fort
également champion du monde
universitaire cette saison et
vice-champion de France Espoir l'athlète
de 50 ans en iine veut continuer de
progresser j'ai des grosses ambitions
pour l'année prochaine ça veut dire sur
triathlon et duathlon j'ai envie de
faire des places des belles places voir
même gagner des titres sur sur des les
championnats d'Europe voir même les
championnats du monde voilà je veux me
rapprocher du top au côté de Frédéric
Belaubre triple champion d'Europe de
triathlon Thomas André continue de
repousser ses limites pour faire retenti
à nouveau la Marseillaise sur un podium
international donc à l'image de de
Thomas André cette belle équipe de de
première division a fait une plutôt
bonne saison avec une 8e place à la fin
oui sur le Grand Prix on a réussi à
notre objectif début de saison c'était
top 10 bon on était un petit peu on est
arrivé en D1 on sait on sait que c'est
un championnat très très relevé c'est
pratiquement un départ de Coupe du monde
à chaque Grand Prix donc on a on l'a
joué jouer profil bas ça s'est
relativement bien passé malgré quelques
mes aventures de blessures les blessures
et les accidents mais ça fait partie du
jeu ça fait partie du jeu et donc on a
réussi à à conquérir cette 8e place dans
le grand prix pour une première année
c'est vraiment super résultat tout le
monde est est satisfait dans le club
c'est c'est très très bien et notre
Thomas qui nous fait deux titres de
champion du monde cette année c'est
vraiment c'est c'est inespéré c'est non
c'est pas inespéré mais c'est bien qu'il
l' fait cette année ça veut dire qui on
l'a mis dans il était dans de bonnes
conditions pour pouvoir réaliser ce
champ de performance ça veut dire dans
sa tête il était bien ça veut dire que
tout s'est bien passé quand ça se passe
bien les résultats ils suivent c'est
mais c'est tellement compliqué de
pouvoir mettre tous les ingrédients
comme on dit dans le petit pot et faire
sortir une victoire c'est c'est ça a
marché cette année tant mieux j'espère
que l'année prochaine il va continuer
sur sur le sur la sur la dynamique et et
nous ramener encore de très beaux
résultats il est pas tout seul il y a
aussi d'autres d'autres triathlètes à
côté de lui on a fait un petit un petit
reportage avec eux justement pour pour
mieux les découvrir et voir que bah dans
cette équipe de SaintQuentin il fait
plutôt bon
vivre on est vraiment vraiment satisfait
des résultats de l'ambiance et de de
tout ce qui s'est passé cette année on a
vraiment ressoué soudé les liens de
l'équipe on s'est bien entendu on s'est
bien amusé et le le résultat est au-delà
de nos
espérances c'est super intéressant
d'avoir fr dans l'équipe parce que il il
nous fait partager un peu son expérience
c'est c'estes connaissances et et du
coup c'est bien mais notre objectif du
coup maintenant c'est c'est essayer de
le dépasser mais c'est pas évidentin
c'est vraiment pas
évident c'est gin Hervé je pense que
tout le monde a répondu à la même chose
ah quoi que quoi que au final non mais
on déconne tous après bon giselin c'est
quelqu'un qui était déjà dans l'équipe
du coup le fait qu'il soit des connards
et tout ça nous a bien intégré mais bon
comme on peut voir au final on est tous
un peu déconneurs et c'est c'est ce qui
donne aussi une ambiance Sapa dans le
groupe quoi donc la clé aussi peut-être
de cette réussite c'est ça comme on le
voyait là c'est cette bonne ambiance
entre entre les athlètes Fred Belot
emeriic et Thomas ouais il y a une bonne
ingration c'est un sport exigeant qui
demande beaucoup d'entraînement beaucoup
de travail donc dès qu'on a un petit
moment si on peut en sortir par le fun
comme on dit hein c'est assez fun comme
sport donc oui ils ont besoin de ça
d'extérioriser tout ça et ça passe aussi
par les liens qu'on crée dans une équipe
la mayonnaise a pris donc bon pour nous
c'est tout bénéfice hein les résultats
suivent B quand c'est comme ça on surf
hein c'est et alors dans le dans les
zvines vous êtes pas le seul club qui
fonctionne puisqu'on connaît
Sartrouville où il y a aussi le le
podium olympique du du triathlon avec
les frères bronley notamment et et
poissi qui qui fonctionne plutôt bien
tout à fait quelle est la recette dans
les ilines pour avoir autant de top
niveau bah c'est né ici hein dans le 78
donc c'est normal c'est le berceau donc
effectivement ça pousse un peu partout
ça sm il y a des gens qui s'intéressent
il y a beaucoup de dirigeants déjà il
faut des dirigeants s'il y a pas de
dirigeants il a pas de club donc il y a
des dirigeants et puis et puis la
mayonnaise elle prend et on a envie et
puis c'est un sport qu'on a envie de
qu'on a envie de médiatiser parce que
franchement il est pas à sa place hein
par rapport et quand vous dit c'est né
ici ça veut dire quoi que tout est parti
d'ici du département 78 ouis ouis tout
pr club jour dans le département tout à
fait VO dans les premiers plus anciens
donc avec les trinosaures aussi qui sont
au mur
TR les
trinosaures c'est pour vous dire que
c'est très
ancien donc en fait oui c'est parti des
Mureaux c'est c'est ancien c'est un
sport enfin c'est ancien non on est pas
là mais alors trop de club ça tue pas le
club justement ça tue pas ce niveau là
trop de concurrence alors qu'on pourrait
faire peut-être un pôle dans les non non
ça c'est l'émulation ah en Île-de-France
le pôle oui on en parle depuis longtemps
oui on souhaiterait avoir une structure
qui permette à nos jeunes de pouvoir
progresser avec et que ça joue une sorte
d'émulation entre tous les clubs de de
l'île-de-fance parce qu'on est quand
même on disons que l'île-de frrance
c'est quand même la Ligue la plus grosse
de France puisque c'est
pratiquement on doit avoir plus de
presque 6000 adhérents maintenant en île
de- France rien que sur le
triathlon et pourtant on peut pas dire
sur la région qui soit propice à la
pratique puisquon est pratiquement C en
cycle urbain pratiquement tout le temps
pourtant on a adhérant donc non ça se
développe bien on a un président qui
s'en occupe un sport qui se développe
bien une bonne saison pour Saint-Quentin
la saison prochaine c'est quoi c'est le
top 5 au sein de l'élite bah on tend
toujours à progresser hein on va faire
tout
pour nos trithlètes sont vraiment
motivés pour aller plus loin ils ont
fait une belle saison mais ils ont envie
de montrer que ils sont capables de
faire encore mieux et nous ça nous
satisfait on essaie de mettre en place
un environnement favorable pour qu'il
puisse pratiquer dans les meilleures
conditions et ça fonctionne he quand
quand ça fonctionne c'est génial quoi on
a des résultats merci jean-fançoir reste
avec nous sur le plateau on rappelle
donc c'est très bon résultats
enregistrés par le club de triathlon de
saint-contin en Yveline la page de sport
se poursuit on reste dans la course
globalement un petit peu avec le
traditionnel parcourir Montini qui avait
lieu ce weekend voici quelques images
justement de de la course puisque notre
notre coner Alice Gastine mordu de
course à pied était présente par on
rvoit sur l'émission de la semaine
dernière voilà exactement parmi les 350
participant donc la caméra embarqué
comme si vous y étiez exactement pour la
petite histoire le vainqueur a bouclé
les 10 km en 57 minutes donc c'est quand
même une belle performance presque
presque 20 à l'heure donc c'est une
performance de triathlète he il y a du
monde au départ il y en a un peu moins
après c'était en tête peut-être
peut-être qu'elle était en tête ou
peut-être qu'elle était un petit peu un
peu en retrait je sais pas en tout cas
elle court vite he VO ça bouge pas Malou
pas mal exactement euh de de la course à
pied à la boxe aucun rapport mais il y a
TR très B Comat qui s'annonce ce weekend
est-ce que wilfri vous connaissez Adila
mumadi si je vous réponds non non est-ce
que c'est grave non c'est pas grave mais
vous allez apprendre à le connaître
c'est l'actuel champion de France des
des super moyens catégorie super moyen
en box il se prépare au combat de sa
carrière qui va avoir lieu le weekend
prochain face à l'impressionnant
britannique James digal nous l'avons
suivi lors de ces derniers entraînements
donc c'est une bonne occasion de le
découvrir et dire qu'il a 3 ans Adila
mouadi a failli raccrocher les gants à
32 ans le boxeur il en Courtois est face
à son plus grand défi conquérir la
ceinture de champion d'Europe des super
moyens mais ce qu'il attend est presque
l'évresse de sa catégorie le jeune
anglais James digal champion olympique
amateur à Pékin l'envie ça va être dans
un premier temps pas forcément de le
détruire non l'envie ça sera tout
simplement de de gagner de gagner de
rentrer avec la ceinture ça va être ma
ma première envie et je je suis parti
pour pour faire mes 12 round si on peut
en faire moin on en fer moins laassé du
monde de la boxe amateur il rencontre
Antoine farouia en 2009 à ses côtés le
boxeur éon cortois connaît une
ascenstion fulgurante des premiers
matchs de gala à la victoire en Coupe de
la Ligue jusqu'au titre de champion de
France il y a quelques mois tout va très
vite pour ce directeur de centre de
loisirs mais il reste les pieds sur
terre ça reste un plaisir et on fait ça
surtout tant que ça reste un plaisir en
tout cas on me verra sur le ring moi je
je compte monter tant que je me ferai
plaisir sur un ring et je me ferai
plaisir en venant à la salage je
continuera à boxer quoi 1 M83 pour 76 kg
ce boxeur d'origine comorienne possède
un physique atypique son envie sa rage
de vaincre peuvent rivaliser avec
l'expérience du Britannique vainqueur
par chaos 9 fois sur ses 12 victoires
moi je pense que l'autre c'est un garçon
complet au niveau boxe il a été champion
olympique comme je vous l'ai dit il est
champion d'Europe donc au niveau
technique tactique c'est quelque chose
de formidable mais ce qu'il n'a pas
c'est ce qu'il a dans les points parce
que j'ai des copains enfin des boxeurs
on va mettre les G travaille il nous
disent il défense les murs donc ça veut
tout dire vous comprenez sil est capable
de défenser les murs il est capable de
défenser un
bonommeune simple relation entraîur
athlète un rapport père F l à et son
coach le duo ne se fixe pas de limite
pour l'instant mais il devra d'abord
franchir l'obstacle anglais pour
continuer de se faire plaisir sur le R